Das ist wirklich eine absolute wetterkatastrophen
moment in den usa und während sich der us-präsident mehr von der globalen erwärmung in die usa wünscht ist dieser kälteeinbruch mit
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit eine direkte folge des klimawandels
Wie kann das sein ein kälteeinbruch als folge der weltweiten erwärmung
Und was sind die konsequenzen für europa also wie ist die lage in den usa und in europa jetzt in science und fiction herzlich willkommen
Temperaturen von knapp minus 40 grad celsius selbst in new york das liegt auf der höhe der
italienischen hauptstadt rom
Sind es minus 20 grad und im sonnenstaat florida schneit es zum ersten mal seit 30 jahren einen bomben zyklon
zieht über die ostküste der usa die folgen sind fatal allein
Am samstag mussten 450 flüge gestrichen werden
am donnerstag waren
24 1000 haushalte ohne strom und das nur in massachusetts und in zahlreichen weiteren us-staaten wurde der notstand ausgerufen
es ist eben eine absolute wetter katastrophe cnn
Meldet 22 tote es ist absolut verrückt und auch tragisch und es ist eine direkte folge des klimawandels
mit an sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
verantwortlich für die kaltluft die in den osten der usa zog ist der polare jetstream darüber herrscht einigkeit in der klimaforschung in einer
Höhe von rund zehn kilometern zieht der mit rund 200 bis 500 kilometern pro stunde
Um die arktis und beeinflusst unser wetter maßgeblich er schiebt hoch und
Tiefdruckgebiete hin und her und je nachdem wie er verläuft kann er kaltluft aus der arktis nach süden
transportieren oder auch warmluft, aus dem süden in den norden eine folge des klimawandels die
jetstreams war nämlich immer stärker nach süden eine folge der immer wärmeren
Arktis die den polaren jetstream schwächt der fängt dadurch an im wahrsten sinne des wortes herum zu eiern beulen
Im stream die sogenannten rost wie wellen werden stärker und führen so automatisch zu wetterextremen
Und sie bleiben einige zeit stabil was das wetterchaos noch verschlimmern sie bringen zurzeit die kalte polarluft
Mit viel schnee weiter in den süden und dann auf dem rückweg warme luft nach norden zwischen solchen
entgegensetzten luftströmung kann dann ein bomben zyklon entstehen der neben den niedrigen temperaturen für weiteres chaos sorgt
zitat seit dem jahreswechsel sieht man deutlich dass der jetstream über
Nordamerika eine würdige form angenommen hat mit winden die kalte arktische luft in den nordosten der usa
transportieren so marlene kretschmer vom potsdam institut für klimafolgenforschung pik
in der zeit aber auch für europa gilt genau dieses szenario
der zusammenhang mit dem klimawandel für europa wurde nämlich inzwischen durch das pk
nachgewiesen die verlangsamung des jetstreams lässt die winter
im nördlichen eurasien kälter werden
so das forschungsergebnis
Das gilt genauso auch für die usa ist damals also auch für die usa kaum von der hand zu weisen die usa werden mit diesem
Wetterphänomenen zu den am stärksten durch den klimawandel betroffenen ländern gehören schätzungen sprechen von schäden
Im bereich von hunderten milliarden dollar die nasa hat jetzt eine karte veröffentlicht die die
temperaturveränderung in amerika illustriert gemessen wurden die
bodentemperaturen in den letzten acht jahren und mit den temperaturen in diesen tagen verglichen das erschreckende
Im nordosten der usa war es fast überall kälter und im südwesten
Überall wärmer und zwar bis zu 15 grad kälter und wärmer es deutet einiges darauf hin als würden die usa in zwei
Temperaturzonen aufgeteilt gehen der einen werden die sommer so heiß sodass die vegetation abbrennt und das wasser ausgeht und der anderen bricht die
Infrastruktur in den extremen wintern zusammen die bewohnbarkeit des gesamten landes wäre gefährdet ein
absolutes horror-szenario aber nicht mehr so ganz unwahrscheinlich und was passiert in europa auch wir müssen uns auch wetterkatastrophen
Wie in den usa einrichten. Im letzten jahr hat gezeigt wie eine
Rossi will einen heftigen sturm innerhalb kürzester zeit nach, zentraleuropa schiebt und diese rossi wäre hätte es
So ohne den klimawandel nicht gegeben wir müssen uns also auch hier auf so einiges gefasst machen hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken cw
Der klimawandel ist schuld wenn er kein video zu diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann sollten wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergessen ich den
Genau auf die glocke und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran